so I'll tell you ahead of time this
problem is no joke but if we do it step
by step it's actually not too bad but
it's not an easy problem so don't get
discouraged if you know you you kind of
don't even know where to start here so
let P of X equal 24 X to the 24th plus
the sum from J equals 1 to 23 if 24
minus J times X to the 24th minus J plus
X to the 24th plus J let Z 1 Z 2 all the
way to Zr be the distinct zeros the of P
of X fair enough
let Z sub K squared equal a sub k plus B
sub K I for K equals 1 through R so
there's Z sub K or I guess Z sub they're
saying just look a sub k plus B sub K I
is going to be the square of each of
these roots so let's see for K is equal
to 1 through R where I is equal to
square root of negative 1 we know that
and a and a sub K and V sub K are real
numbers let the sum from k equal 1 are
of the absolute value of B sub K equal
this number over here where m N and P
are integers and P is not divisible by
the square of any prime so they're
saying that we've just simplified the
radical as much as possible find M plus
n plus P so this sum right here this is
the sum of the absolute value of the
imaginary parts of the square of the
roots right B sub K is the imaginary
part of the square of root of root K I
guess you could call it and so what
we're going to do is take the absolute
value of the imaginary part of the
square of the roots and sum them up so
before we even think about how to do
that let's just let's just try to
visualize this polynomial a little
better and I have a feeling this is
going to take us multiple videos to do
so we have P of X is equal to well the
first term here is just 24 well it's not
the first number is the first term as
the way it's written first term could be
anything 24 X to the 24th and now let's
write out let's not write out this over
here so if we set J equal to 1 what do
we get we get 23 23 times X to the 23 x
to the 23 plus X to the 25 all right
this is 24 plus J plus X to the 25 and
then when J is equal to 2
I'll just go down in a big column here
when J is equal to two we have plus 22x
to the 22 plus X to the 26 and then we
could keep going plus I'll just keep you
get the general idea this term over here
the the coefficients are going to go
down so is this exponent but this
exponent over here is going to go up so
then we can keep adding all the way
let's go - lets go to J equal 22 so when
J is equal to 20 to 24 - 22 is 2 it's
going to be 2x squared 22 plus 24 is 46
so plus X to the X to the 46 I did it
right 22
right 46 and then this last term over
here when J is equal to 23 because
that's where we stopped we're going to
get 1 times X plus X to the 47th so
that's our polynomial what I want to do
is I'm just going to rewrite this in
kind of the way we're traditional we're
used to seeing polynomials and that's
you know I start with the highest degree
term and then you go down from there so
we can write P of X we can rewrite P of
X as being equal to what's the highest
degree term here well we have an X to
the 47th over here right over here X to
the 47th and then a coefficient here is
1 if you distribute it so it's going to
be it's going to be X to the 47th X to
the 47th Plus this term over here 2 X to
the 46 I'm just distributing this
multiplying factor or this I guess it's
coefficient it's going to be 2x squared
+ 2 X to the 46 and then we're just
going to keep going we're going to keep
going all the way down all the way up to
22 X to the 26 22 X to the 26 so you see
what's happening the coefficient is
increasing by 1 each time and the
exponent is decreasing by 1 + 23 + 23 X
to the 25th and then the next degree we
don't have a 20 X to the 24th year but
we have the X to the 24th right there it
so it seems almost by design for the
problem that they stuck it there so plus
24 X to the 24th and now we can do all
of these terms here so we have plus 23
plus 23 plus 23 x to the 23rd plus 22x
to this 22nd and then we go all the way
down to plus 2x squared plus X so this
is just another way so that at least in
my brain simplifies this polynomial a
good bit we now have a good sense of
what's happening here it's really all of
the powers of X up to up to the 47th
power and then the coefficients started
1 and they keep increasing up to 24 and
then they start decreasing again now
we're interested in the roots of this
polynomial and there's one root that's
pretty easy to find we can just factor
an X out of this every term here is
divisible by X so we can rewrite P of X
P of X is equal to x times it's equal to
x times X to the 46 plus 2x to the 45th
well I'm just dividing all of these by X
or factoring out an X plus all the way
to 22 X to the 25th plus 23 X to the 24
and then we have the one in magenta plus
24x to the 23rd and then we have all of
these characters down here so then we
have plus 23 X to the 22nd plus 22x to
the 21 all the way to 2x plus 1 now x
equals 0 is clearly a root if you set P
of x equals 0 x equals 0 as root it's
actually not going to matter much
because it has no imaginary part so if
you take 0 one of the roots here is 0
you square 0 it's not going to have an
imaginary part so the absolute value of
its imaginary part is not going to
contribute to this sum over here but
maybe it simplifies this so we really
care about the sum of the roots other
than 0 so we care about the sum of the
roots of everything else all the stuff
in parenthesis and this part I guess the
next step it might not be obvious to you
but now that once you see it once you
see the pattern I guess if you ever see
it again in your life maybe in some of
these ami type problems or competition
problems you should be able to recognize
it because it's an easy pattern to
recognize it's just not something you
normally see in your everyday curriculum
and so what
do to see the pattern here to see the
pattern is think about what happens when
we square different polynomials so if we
square if we square where all of the
coefficients are one they don't all have
to be one but it'll help us see the
pattern there the pattern will obviously
be slightly different if the
coefficients are different now if I just
take X plus one so X plus one X plus one
squared is x squared plus two x plus one
we've seen that multiple times now what
is x squared what is x squared plus X
plus one squared so all I'm doing is I'm
just taking all of the powers of X and
summing them up well that's going to be
let me just well we've done enough
practice with this and if you're
watching this problem you know how to do
this it's going to be x squared times x
squared so it's going to be X to the
fourth plus x squared times X which is
going to be X to the third plus x
squared times one which is going to be x
squared plus x times x squared which is
going to be is going to be X to the
third plus x times X which is going to
be x squared plus x times one which is
going to be X and then finally it's
going to be one times all of this stuff
which is going to be plus x squared plus
X plus one and so if you take the sum
you're going to get X to the fourth plus
two x to the third plus three x squared
plus 2x plus one and so you might
already see a pattern emerging what
happened over here when you just took X
plus one squared you started with the
one you went up to a two and then you
went back to one so not clear that you
have a pattern but it seems to have this
the coefficients increase and then
decrease what happens when you took this
thing squared
you started with a 1 then the
coefficients went one two three the
middle term the three peaked out at the
hot at D I guess the middle term and
then you start going down in coefficient
again one two three and then two one and
you can actually prove that this is the
case for any problem so I could just
write out I won't multiply it out if you
have time you can do it but if I were to
take X to the third plus X to the third
plus x squared plus X
plus one if I were to square this I just
based on the pattern and you could do it
on paper if you like you hopefully know
how to multiply this this type of
polynomial there are videos on it if you
don't this is going to be equal to the
highest degree term is going to be X to
the sixth so it's going to be one X to
the sixth plus two X to the fifth plus
three X to the fourth plus and we have
to be careful the middle term so this is
going to have this right here is going
to have you're going to have each of
these terms x also the last term is
going to be so you're going to have X to
the fourth let me write not write the
coefficients you're gonna have X to the
fourth plus something times X to the
third plus something times x squared
plus something times X plus one so
you're gonna have one two three four
five six seven terms the middle term is
going to be this right over here so
that's where we peak out our
coefficients and then they go back down
again
three two oh sorry it should be three
whoops 4x and three then two and then
one again and you multiply this out for
yourself but I think you now see the
pattern so when you look at this thing
here where the coefficients are just
going from 1 2 all the way to 24 is
where they peak out and notice they
peaked out the middle term where you're
peaking out in this case is really the
highest so we were picking out here at
the X to the third term and this was a
third-degree polynomial that we were
squaring over here we peaked out at the
x squared term and this was a
second-degree polynomial we were
squaring here we peak out of the X term
and this was a first degree polynomial
we're squaring this is the exact same
pattern but we peak out we peak out at X
to the 23rd at X to the 23rd so using
the same pattern using that and you can
actually prove it for the general case
it just gets messy and I think you you
get the general gist of it this thing
over here and this is what I talked
about it's not the easiest thing in the
world to recognize P of X can be
re-written as equal to x times this
thing over here is X to the 23rd X to
the 23rd plus X to the 22nd plus X to
the 21st plus X to the
xxi all the way down to plus X to the
third plus x squared plus X plus one
squared squared and we know that don't
we and you know the only way you'd
really know that is if you've seen this
pattern before if you've seen this
pattern before but that's the way you do
it you look at this is a pattern the
coefficient is just keep increasing the
24 then keep decreasing that's going to
be whatever the coefficient the highest
degree over here so it's extra 23 it's
going to be extra 23 plus all the powers
of X less than that all the way down to
X to 0 squared and we saw the pattern
here a couple of times I'm gonna leave
you in this video this simplifies it a
good bit but there's going to be a few
more kind of aha moments to be able to
that we're gonna have to have to be able
to solve this problem